I want all Muslims deported now step in
puck undercut the nose all right knock
akita then we could torture only wanton
who won't be Iraqis were torturing it'll
be all these Patriots hot wives and
their kids to stab them with it
stab stab stab that's by a billion cuts
so start shoving the knife in ladies and
gentlemen he stabbed them to death step
in Punk you're undercut the knows their
whole nose would just tear off a blood
spring out everywhere yeah I want my
listeners to hunt them down all right
knock akita yeah yeah and I want you to
rise up and get fired up and get angry
and just just start grinding your teeth
Jeremy Christian police say this man
verbally attacked a Muslim woman on a
train and that when Good Samaritans came
forward to help he stabbed them to death
I'm calling for all mosques in the
United States to be shut down and I'm
calling for all self-identifying Muslims
of any type to be deported to their
original country of origin even if it
was they've been here 200 years I want
all Muslims deported now and I want all
Muslims to have their mosque shut down
and their minarets removed white
supremacist accused of stabbing two good
Samaritans to death on a commuter train
in Portland first half on the neck
together any stomach a man identifying
himself as Jeremy Christian I'm God dude
Oh on our zilla's artificial Word of God
in a race washing sacred ready giving a
Nazi salute and yelling racist expletive
young women one of them wearing a hijab
boarded the train and Jeremy Christian
immediately went on a hate-filled tirade
then pulled out a knife and attacked
them then I see that there's just blood
everywhere looked like every punch that
I saw was actually a stab police say 53
year old Ricky best died at the scene
and 23 year-old talisha Nam KY mache was
pronounced dead at a hospital
Jeremy Christian